[Music]
she was the biggest star of the 2004
games but when the competition ends
where do you
go you got to be [__] kidding
me for bronze medalist hope and Gregory
you go home all of America talking about
your [__] bronze I am a gold medalist
you don't want to [__] with
me [__] with whoever I want whenever I
want I'll [__] with them so hard I'll
rip their taints in half then I'll wear
one part of the taint and a lock it
around my neck give the other half of
the taint locket to your mom just shove
up her
ass Twitchy yeah uh no one really calls
me that anymore uh in fact you were the
only person that that did it look so
different oh really but that's still
there so now I see it I'm a Bia check
the resume have you thought anymore
about working at the gym I'm not a coach
I'm a star I was on Dancing With the
Stars it's not called dancing with the
coaches I'm going to show you how to be
judge B cute to the right cute to the
left not I'm cute not I'm cute sell it
to the [__] ass judges
up